hello everyone today we are going to
talk about genomic variation in ngs data
so let's first talk about variant
calling variant calling refers to the
task of identifying possible variations
in genomic or transcriptomic sequences
with respect to a chosen reference
sequence
in germline variant calling the
reference sequences is the standard for
the species of interest for somatic
variant calling the reference is the
genome of a chosen control somatic cell
sample
in this tutorial we will analyze next
generation sequencing data collected
from two individuals with primary ductal
carcinoma and perform a somatic variant
calling analysis from each individual
cell lines were generated from cancerous
that were taken from the tumor and
non-cancerous taken from the blood cell
samples exome sequencing was then
performed on the cell lines for the
purpose of identifying variants
associated with the cancer
exome sequencing is a method for
selectively sequencing only the coding
regions of a genome as mentioned in the
previous section the formation of a
tumor is associated with the disruption
of various genes and these are a class
of genes known as tumor suppressor genes
which prevent cancer development by
regulating the cell cycle stages of
growth and division
we will create a pipeline using the t
bioinfo platform to process paired and
read data from each pair of matched
tumor normal cell lines and identify
variants between cancerous and
non-cancerous cell genomes before you
can start the practical tutorial make
sure you have the access
for the t-bioinfo platform which is
separate from the omixlogic learn portal
access
so for the analysis we will use four
cell lines two pairs of cancerous and
normal samples characteristics and
culture methods for each cell lines are
available at the american type culture
collection website you can find the two
cell line pairs in the description of
this tutorial
the sec codes are identifiers for the
cell lines in the atcc database and the
srr codes are identifiers for the
sequence data from the respective cell
lines sequencing was done using an
illumina genome analyzer the pair and
read data exist in the sra database
under these file names
so now let's begin with the tutorial
we will run a separate pipeline for each
cell line pair before uploading our exam
sequence data to the platform we must
specify several parameters the type of
reference genome we are using for
alignment of the reeds is a model
organism that is homo sapiens
with annotation a gtfi 5 is a typical
genomic annotation file format this
reference genome type is specified by
our model genome gtf our read data is
spare end and in fastq format as
mentioned several human reference
genomes exist and we will use a recent
one that is homo sapiens grch38
there is an option to upload files
directly from your computer or to pass a
download link to the server for
uploading
as mentioned previously the necessary
data files have been stored at the
server
the file paths are specified using the
svl link option
the following file paths should be
pasted in two file link fields
the description of the same you can find
here on the screen and also in the
description
we divide the cancerous and normal
samples into two groups
after providing the input file paths
select define groups check
in the new window you will see an empty
box labeled group a
select the positive next to the label to
create a second group group b
you may now drag and drop the samples
into the desired groups
for this variant calling pipeline be
sure to place cancerous samples into
group a and non-cancerous samples into
group b
we are now ready to create our pipeline
notice that the t bioinfo pipeline
interface is organized into various
sections of vertically stacked buttons
the buttons indicate various algorithms
or processes and each stack contains
processes with a similar function
after selecting start the processes to
run in sequence may be selected left to
right
with each button opening a window
providing an explanation of the process
and the option to adjust any available
parameters various processes apply to
the various types of input data and
during the pipeline creation the
highlighted buttons indicate processes
which are compatible with the output of
the previously selected process
as discussed in the overview the primary
subroutines of genomic variant analysis
are mapping reads to a reference genome
and variant calling
note the two vertical pipeline sections
for mapping and variant calling for this
example we will be using mapping
algorithm boutique 2 and variant calling
algorithms tirelka
you can learn more about the algorithms
in the lesson on the omixlogic learn
portal
now to view the output files after
completion
select the downward arrow icon in the
entry for the desired pipeline
click on the files with the
extension.vcf to download them
the detected snp variants will be
investigated in the next section
in the table below is a random sample of
single nucleotide variants detected in
the tumor samples of the basal breast
cancer patients using the pipeline
detailed above
these are contained in the resulting vcf
file labeled with dot smb.sterelkar.vcf
the chrome and pause fields provide the
chromosome name and position in the
sequence of the variant respectively
the ref field provides the nucleotide
existing in the reference genome at the
corresponding position
and the alt provides the variant
nucleotide
coal provides a fret quality score
associated with each snv
based on the frequency of the variant in
the tumor rate versus the normal rates
now you can run the second pipeline
performing the same steps with the
samples that could be seen here on the
screen and also i'll provide the same in
the description
the results that are obtained by running
the variant calling analysis pipeline
you can view the results in the
integrated genomics viewer to learn how
the analysis is carried out in the igev
you can refer to lesson number five in
the genomics course on omixlogic learn
portal
in this lesson you will learn to create
a pipeline for variant calling using the
t bioinfo platform the same that we
discussed today and to process payout
entry data from each pair of mashed
tumor normal cell lines and identify
variants between cancerous and
non-cancerous cell genomes